Speaker 1: We now have heard from former national
security adviser John Bolton and former attorney
to Donald Trump and friend of the show, Michael
Cohen.
Both believe that Donald Trump probably has
won more documents at some of his other houses.
And number two, even copies of the documents
that were seized by the FBI.
And it really wouldn't be surprising that
both are true.
Let's first listen to Trump's former national
security adviser, John Bolton.
Not a guy that I like politically.
I think he is a depraved warmongering individual.
But I've not known him to be overtly dishonest
in interviews that he does when it comes to
just basic factual matters.
Sure, he'll distort about the case for war.
He's done that before.
But he has appeared to be completely straightforward,
at least on factual matters of this sort.
Take a listen to what he had to say when he
was interviewed.
Speaker 2: Well, given that it's Donald Trump
we're talking about, I'm not surprised in
the slightest.
And I wouldn't be surprised if there were
more highly classified documents at Bedminster
or some some other residents of his.
I just think it's important that everybody,
whether they're pro-Trump or anti-Trump or
whatever their position is, to try and take
a deep breath here and let this process play
out.
You know, the filing that was done last night
in the United States, that included that picture
that you've shown there and a lot of information
about the documents and about Trump's obstruction
is the word they used.
The refusal to turn them over to the National
Archives is revealing bit by bit the seriousness
of the case, and we don't know all the details
yet.
It could be very, very serious.
But my strong urging to everybody is stay
calm.
Let's let it play out.
We've got due process in the United States.
The facts will come out here.
But let's not jump to conclusions that the
Justice Department is an arm of the Democratic
Party on the one hand or the Trump to go to
jail tomorrow on the other.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
And of course, there's no evidence that this
Justice Department investigation is operating
at the direction of Joe Biden or any such
thing.
Now, we heard something similar from Michael
Cohen.
Michael Cohen tweeted, quote, I have been
saying since the FBI, I have been saying this
since the FBI raid.
I believe Trump has copies, potentially other
documents as well at other locations, including
his children's homes.
Weisselberg's Florida Home.
Allen Weisselberg is the CFO now indicted
of Trump's business Bedminster, New Jersey
golf course, Fifth Avenue apartment, etc..
Now, if this is true and it's completely plausibly
true, there are probably foreign spies already
trying to infiltrate those locations with
how easy it has been for foreign agents to
get into Mar a Lago over the last few years.
It would not be shocking at all that some
of our adversaries are already looking at
whether Donald Trump has other documents or
copies of documents that some of his other
homes and, you know, we talked earlier about
is the DOJ being political?
If they are deliberately waiting until after
the midterms to indict Trump, the more I learn,
the more it sounds like they're nowhere near
ready to charge because they may need to have
more search warrants.
They may need to try to find documents at
other of Trump's homes.
The way things are looking and at this point,
from a national security standpoint, it has
to be assumed that everything is compromised.
All of the at any of these documents that
Trump took, it has to be assumed that our
adversaries may have gotten their hands on
them.
It has to be assumed that there are copies
because it's Trump, after all.
And the person who is now trying to clean
up this mess but only making things worse,
is Donald Trump's spokeswoman, Liz Harrington.
Let's talk about her next.